what i want to do is another proofy-like
thing to think about the sum of an
infinite geometric series and it will
use a very similar idea to what we use
to find the sum of a finite geometric
series so let's say i have a geometric
series an infinite geometric series so
we're going to start at k equals 0 and
we're going to go we're never going to
stop we're going to go it's going all
the way to infinity so we're never going
to stop adding terms here and it's going
to be our first term times our common
ratio our common ratio to the k-th power
to the k-th power actually we do k in
that color k equals zero
all the way
to infinity
and so let's just call this let's just
call this thing right over here let's
call this
s
sub
let's call this s sub
infinity we're going all the way to
infinity right over here and we're gonna
and so this if we were to expand it out
is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to a times r to
the 0. actually let me just write it out
like that which is just
just a
a times
r
to the 0 power
plus a times r
to the first power
r to the first power
plus a times r
to the second power
r to the
second power
plus and we could just keep going let me
do one more plus a actually we could
just keep going on and on and on i think
you get the general idea
now just like when we try to find derive
a formula for the sum of a finite
geometric series we just said well what
happens if you take this sum and if you
were to multiply every term by your
common ratio every term by r so let's do
that let's imagine this sum and we're
going to multiply every term by r and
the reason why i said this is proof e is
this is not always clear what it's it's
a little bit when you're multiplying
something times an infinite terms or an
infinite sum at least this will at least
give you the general idea when you start
thinking about infinity you sometimes
have to think about things a little bit
deeper
so r
times this infinite sum
well that's going to be equal to
we're going to multiply every term here
times r
so a r to the 0 power times r is going
to be
a
times r
a times r to the first power
multiply this one times r you're going
to get
a times r to the second power
a times r to the second bar i think you
see where this is going multiply this
one times r you're gonna get
plus
a times r
to the third power and we would just
keep on going
we just keep on going
so let me just show that so plus dot dot
dot
now what happens if we were to subtract
this
sum from this top sum so on the left
hand side we could express that as our
sum
we could express that as our sum s sub
infinity
minus
our common ratio times s sub infinity
s of infinity is going to be equal to
so when you subtract you're going to
have a times r to the 0 power which is
really just the same thing as a
that's just going to be a a times r to 0
is just a times 1 which is a
we read that same color is equal to a
but every other term you're gonna have a
times r to the first but then you're
gonna subtract a times r to the first
you're gonna have a times r to the
second we're gonna subtract a times r to
the second so every other term is going
to be subtracted is going to be
subtracted away and this happens all the
way
all the way to infinity it never never
ends so the only term that you're left
with is just that first one is just a
and so now we can actually try to solve
for our sum if you factor out the s sub
infinity
you are left with
1 minus r
minus r
s times s our sum times 1 minus r is
equal to a divide both sides by 1 minus
r and we get that our sum the thing that
we cared about and once again this is
kind of an amazing result that we're
taking the sum of an infinite number of
terms and under the proper constraints
we are going to get we are going to get
a finite value so this is going to be
equal to
a
this is going to be equal to a
over
1 minus r
so once again it's kind of neat if i was
to say i had let's say i had the sum
i don't know say we started with
five
and then each time we were to multiply
by i don't know three fifths so three so
five plus three fifths times five is
three
times three fifths is going to be nine
fifths
nine fifths or i multiply by three
again then i'm or sorry not nine fifths
so five
my brain isn't working right five times
three fifths is going to be three
times three fifths is going to be
it's going to be three times this it's
gonna be nine fifths actually no that
was right my brain is working right
times three
fifths is going to be 27 over 25 times
three fifths is going to be this is
going to be 81 over 125 and we keep on
going on and on and on forever and
notice these terms are starting to get
smaller and smaller and smaller actually
all of them we're getting smaller and
smaller and smaller we're multiplying by
three-fifths every time we now know what
the sum is going to be it's going to be
our first term is going to be five
over one minus our common ratio and our
common ratio in this case is
three-fifths so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to five over
two-fifths which is the same thing as 5
times
5 over 2 which is 25 over 2
which is equal to 12
and a half or 12.5 once again amazing
result i'm taking an infinite a sum of
infinite terms here and i was able to
get a finite result and once again when
does this happen
well if our common ratio if the absolute
value of our common ratio is less than
one then these terms are going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller and
you'll even see here in this it even
works out mathematically in this
denominator that you are going to get a
a reasonable answer and it makes sense
because these terms are getting smaller
and smaller and smaller that this thing
will converge even if r is zero if r is
zero we're still not really dealing
we're not anymore dealing strictly with
a geometric series anymore but obviously
if r was zero then everything then
you're really only going to have this
well even this first term is kind of
under debate depending on how you define
what 0 to 0 is but if your first term
you just said would be a then clearly
you'd just be left with a is the sum and
a over 1 minus 0 is still a so this this
formula that we just derived does hold
up for that it does start to break down
if r is equal to one or negative one if
r is equal to one then as you imagine
here you just have a plus a plus a plus
a going on and on forever if r is equal
to negative one you just keep
oscillating a a
minus a plus a minus a and so the sum's
value keeps oscillating between two
values so in general this infinite
geometric series is going to converge if
the absolute value of your common ratio
is less than one or another way of
saying that if your your common ratio is
between one and negative one